[Applause]
please be seated
bravas cotesworth executive vice
president Madigan faculty colleagues
alumni masters candidates and their
families and friends good afternoon and
welcome to convocation for masters
candidates in the Graduate School of
Arts and Sciences I thank all of you for
coming to celebrate the accomplishments
of our masters candidates we honor today
a stellar group of students that on
commencement this coming Wednesday will
join the ranks of our over 40,000 alumni
and who will embark on professional and
academic careers around the world in the
great tradition of Columbia University
equally important we also honor today
the families and friends of our
candidates and today especially to the
mothers among them
who haven't viewed with them the rigors
of their academic pursuits thank you for
being so supportive and understanding I
would ask all masters candidates to rise
and applaud those friends and family
members who have helped them to be here
today
[Music]
the student remarks to the graduating
class will be offered by mr. Eddie so
celkon mr. rose Elton graduated from
SUNY College at Old Westbury with a
degree in sociology and will graduate
from Columbia with an MA in American
Studies his recent his research
interests focus on issues of class and
race within the purview of hip-hop
culture as both a rapper and a graduate
student mr. Elkins thrives in his own
words to bridge the chasm and knowledge
between the realms of hip-hop and
academia mr. Felton
hello everyone and peace who we had no
where's this everyone sac you guys all
right so Thank You Dean Alonzo Provost
Cote worth executive vice president
Madigan members of the faculty
administration and staff family friends
and my fellow graduates for coming to
celebrate the Masters graduating class
of 2017 and a happy Mother's Day in its
mulcher world we should cherish moments
like these that serve as harbingers for
the realization of the varied
aspirations clothes under the sea of
blue as I look around this amalgamation
of stone and ambition a curious feeling
of bittersweet contention fills my eyes
with pride and disillusionment my lungs
with the disconcerting scent of a
relinquished friendship my stint at
Columbia has reached its final moments
my time here is the transformative
experience to say the least
I learned a lot about myself from the
world a mix of precarious uncertainty of
the social political and economic moment
we call the president this campus and
the friends I've made here have remained
a beacon of hope and a bastion of
creativity well I do not spend my free
time in clubs on campus the American
Studies department became my home dr.
Sandler the director my program was my
professor advisor and confidant while my
frequent visits were not always
announced beforehand dr. Sandler
listened to my ramps and provided me
with a much-needed outside perspective
on the trials and tribulations of
Graduate Studies the music department
was also receptive to my intrusions as a
foreigner to their discipline
I took an ethnographic methods class my
first semester with dr. Fox who would
subsequently become my thesis advisor I
went on to take more music courses and
found myself in dodge Hall often my
cohort in particular is scattered among
the many buildings on campus so finding
another departmental home was essential
for us due to our interdisciplinary
program however the freedom of this
program is what drew me to Columbia in
the first place I truly enjoyed every
class that I took because it was crafted
by my eclectic theoretical foundations
culminating in my introduced dysentery
research on the hip hop cypher this
mixture of disciplines provides us with
a more comprehensive analysis of the
world around us our political battles
are based on sociological economic and
psychological perspectives so as
academics we should try to reciprocate
in turn everyone is an ethnographer of
their own experience
reflexivity should be a focal point in
every student's education because it
helps one grow as a researcher and as a
human being I expected a dearth of
humanity on this campus inside the
hallowed halls of the Ivy League I
imagined the realm of legacies elitist
snobs who knew nothing about the plight
of those not born into wealth
I was certainly privileged but still
felt distant from this insulated
prestige I graduated from SUNY College
at Old Westbury in 2015 with the first
graduating class of over a thousand
students I went to school with working
parents kids who work full time to
afford an education and students
struggling with loans I myself worked
for jobs during my undergraduate years
to keep up with the financial demands
through it all I saw the beautiful
painful struggle
of human existence I thought that
Colombia would never reveal that side of
the human condition to this day the
students and faculty here are a
testament to the true diversity of
experience that I hope to encounter
moreover moving to Manhattan catalyzed
the profound metamorphosis in my
worldview the most significant of these
changes was my immersion in hip-hop
culture
navigating the New York underground
fulfilled my research goals and allowed
me to hone my craft as an MC well I'm
still learning I would not have fully
realized as transformation in my native
Long Island's a large part of my
research is the impact that hip-hop has
had on my life over the last two years
it provided a creative outlet a chance
to meet people outside of school and
most importantly a humanistic philosophy
that is unique to hip-hop culture the
community that my rap group creates and
maintains is an intimate collective that
sincerely speaks to the potential of
human nature I've brought this humanism
into my research my music my
relationships and my life I hope that
all of you who are graduating today and
that similar experiences during your
time here it is with this belief in
humanity and the hope I have for this
country that I wish the graduating class
all the best in their future endeavors
we do not need luck
with hard work persistence and an open
minds these are the cornerstones of
Columbia's spirit and pedagogy I know
that you all have great aspirations for
the future and I have no doubt in my
mind they will all become great leaders
and role models and whatever field you
choose to inhabit as for me I hope to
inspire change although the path will be
filled with success and failures I'm
determined to become president someday
I believe that life experience is much
more than the notes you take I believe
that the real world outside of college
is not as daunting as people make it out
to be I believe in me and I believe in
you
I believe that anything is possible with
the right tools and the knowledge of our
ignorance be humble in the face of
success proud in the face of adversity
and steadfast to your convictions most
importantly be you thank you for
congratulations class of 2017
Thank You mr. Ozark on the keynote
address will be offered by Professor
Sunil Gulati mr. Gulati is a senior
lecturer in the Department of Economics
and serves as president of the US Soccer
Federation he graduated magna laude
from Bucknell University in 1981 before
earning MA and MPhil degrees from
Columbia
he is a passionate and popular teacher
at the university president of the Delta
Phi Beta Kappa chapter on campus and has
been at the forefront of soccers growth
in the United States in the last 30
years
professor Gulati we we recognize the
mothers on our left in our right but in
a group of this size my statistics
background tells me there must be some
mothers in this group are there any
mothers in this group please stand
you've got to take a bow for us come on
come on up
bravo Bravo well done
Provost cotesworth executive vice
president Madigan members of the faculty
professor Bernard Cellini there's life
lesson number one professor celanese the
chair the Economics Department if your
boss is in the audience
recognize him always and most
importantly of all of course the
graduates their friends and their
families ladies and gentlemen good
afternoon when Dean Alonzo asked me if
I'd be willing to speak at today's
convocation I hesitated and replied that
it would make much more sense to have a
faculty member who taught regularly at
GSA s he sent me a note back his exact
response we typically invite speakers
who can provide students with insight
and inspiration this year we decided to
go in a different direction Thank You
Dean Alonzo I'll come back to you in a
minute
I thought about it and decided I'd be
honored to speak today for several
reasons one as the Dean mentioned I've
got a couple degrees from Columbia GSA s
to some of you there's a few of you in
the audience there were former students
of mine in principles of economics third
I spoke at my high school graduation and
then again my university undergraduate
institution and a commencement ceremony
so I thought why not for the trifecta
and later on today I'm going to be
trying to reach the principal of my
elementary school to see if they'll have
me and of course the most important
reason I said yes is this is Columbia
and one never says no to Columbia having
accepted the invitation to speak I then
turned to the hard part writing a speech
although I very much enjoy lecturing and
public commentary especially in my
soccer life I rarely write speeches and
most of my interactions are just that
their interactions this today is more or
less a one-way deal furthermore most of
us and my guess is most of you don't
recall who spoke at your undergraduate
graduations or any other graduations or
anything they had to say so how do you
make it memorable not easy
the challenge became writing a sort of
off-the-cuff non speech that would be
memorable in a positive way no need to
provide insider inspiration dean alonso
had already taken care of that problem
for me in this preamble i should mention
that i have an advantage over everyone
else speaking today because I didn't
write this speech in time to send them a
copy so always no concern for the
administration you could say anything
so my off the cup plan planned it
prevented me from sending my non-speech
comments to the dean's office in advance
this led to an interesting idea
the Dean is going to speak twice today
he spoke very briefly early and he's got
some closing remarks I thought this
would be interesting why don't I read
the Dean speech it would be memorable
for one of two reasons either he would
come up and have nothing to say in which
case it would look bad and you'd all
remember that or or he would be
extraordinarily gifted and prompt you
and do what President Clinton did some
years ago with his teleprompter broke
down and give the speech of a lifetime
and you'd remember all of that clearly
the first way was the right way to go
but I have to think about this
I asked Dean Solomon who's seated here
next to me she was my student 30 years
ago believe it or not she asked me to
mention that she was only four years old
at the time I asked her I don't know the
Dean very well how would he react to the
theft of his speech how would he react
to having to give impromptu words he
emailed to me read as follows so let me
understand this in our most important
celebratory event of the year with the
provost and the Dean in attendance your
plan is to embarrass Dean Alonso your
host and boss twice removed
professor galati even with the
unemployment rate at almost all-time
lows I'd reconsider that plan especially
given your non tenured position with the
University
okay none of that is true
unless you consider alternative truth
true what imagine how good it be if it
was late night before I try to live up
to the Dean's request to do something
other than be inspirational and provide
insight let me address the parents for a
minute all of you are very very proud of
your kids today of your adult kids today
as well you should be and this is a day
where no one should be able to tell you
yeah but they're not as good as you
think they're extraordinary a lot of
what I do in my soccer life when we have
millions of registered players is to try
to tell parents okay just because Tommy
can take the ball four straight times up
in the air doesn't mean he's going to be
in the Olympics and you should take it
easy let him just play and so on don't
put so much pressure on them and whatnot
I have an eleven year old or she was 11
last year 12 this year so I went to her
track me last year she plays soccer and
also runs track and in this first track
meet I had been in and the first one she
had run in she won the 800 meters from
start to finish she led the race great
on the way home I asked my wife why
don't you drive today and she said okay
I'll Drive meanwhile in the drive home I
spent most of the time I'm not on the
internet trying to find the age group
national records for the 800 meters for
11 year olds it's okay to take great
pride and expect nothing but
extraordinary things from our children
all right on to the serious stuff more
often than not I get my insight and
inspiration for my students in everyday
dealings and you're going to hear about
some of those including one that
happened about an hour ago not one of my
students but one of your classmates let
me give you a few case studies that are
fresh in my mind about some of those
dealings and which have taken place
relatively recently some years ago
former student of mine came by my office
she had an undergraduate degree from
Columbia and a master's degree from a
very prestigious School on the west
coast and she came in because she didn't
have a job at the time and she said you
know I just expected with a degree from
Columbia and this other school I'd have
a job and she immediately followed that
with you know God that sounds so elitist
I don't mean to sound elitist and I said
that doesn't sound elitist fortune this
was at a time where a particular
vice-presidential candidate had made it
perhaps the fashion not to have gone to
a terrific school it's okay to be proud
of this place two of your
accomplishments it's absolutely right to
be proud of your accomplishments and of
this university there are days where
I've given a talk and said today
literally two yards from where I am is
the center of the universe sundial at
Columbia and that theme sort of goes
well Columbia's sundial is a center of
Columbia Columbia is the center of New
York New York is the center of the
United States the United States the
center of the world the world of course
is the center of the universe Copernicus
notwithstanding I don't think we need
any more people whether it's here in
Washington telling us that the United
States is the center of the universe
these days but today it is the center
today is the center of the universe for
all of you and you'd be commended for
that so life wisdom number two be proud
of your accomplishments here and
elsewhere several months ago I sent an
email to a former student another former
student 25 years ago she graduated from
cipa and back then she was thinking
about what you want to do with her life
very puzzled confused concerned and I
gave her a book and the name of the book
many of you are familiar with it's what
color is my parachute written by a guy
named Richard Bolles
who passed away some years some months
ago and I hadn't talked to this woman in
25 years but I tracked her down the way
we all do now on LinkedIn and sent her a
note said if you are the same Blanc
Blanc that you were then I was just
thinking about this book and so on to my
great surprise and pleasure she wrote
back a few days ago and let me read you
her email what a great treat to find a
message from you
side side life message here there's
nothing faculty like more than hearing
things like that from former students
well perhaps one other thing which is
hey professor
you know those friends and family shares
I gave you at startup they're now worth
600 million no computer folks we would
you know feel free to hand those out
afterwards so the rest of her message
what a great treat to find a message
from you I was ahead of you I thought of
the four days before Bulls death when I
picked up the new addition for my eldest
son I was immediately awash in thinking
about that time when all paths seemed
equally open and
risky now that I have my own young man
trying to figure out the working world
of adults I find myself falling often
into mental or perhaps emotional time
travel life's lesson three uncertainty
is okay
uncertainty is okay many of you don't
know what's next that's okay
and literally an hour ago as I was
walking here I ran into one of the one
of the graduates today in global
politics and he was dressed and I said
where you're going he said here I told
him I was speaking today said what's
next he said I'll be interning at the UN
and I said what happens and he said and
hopefully something will come of that
it'll come of that you don't need to
hope very much it'll come of that but
you don't need to know all of that today
some years ago four years ago I had a
student here who was introduced to me by
by the admissions folks and we talked
for a while he hadn't decided on
Columbia and the outlined what he wanted
to do and some of what he had done and
as a 16 year old he had started an
orphanage and funded it in his home
country in Asia we talked about why I
won't get into the specific and he
talked about one of you wanted to do
with his life and he comes from a very
very affluent family and I said when I
met his father and we didn't do it in
English we did it with a chance later I
said I'm not sure if your son is going
to do the sorts of things Bill Gates did
in the first half of his life but I'm
pretty sure he's going to do the sorts
of things that Bill Gates has done in
the second half of life this is a 16
year old he did it generosity and
empathy aren't a function of age but of
your own spirit important lessons along
the way on Thursday
three days ago which is one of the
reasons I can't write these speeches
very far in advance because I rely on
events of the last few days on Thursday
I was in Bahrain and I met a young man
who came up and introduced himself to me
he graduated last year from Columbia
Business School and he was involved in
sports and we were at a sports
convention so to speak you had never
taken a course that I teach here in
sports including at the Business School
so both had spent multiple years on
campus never had met him never walked
over and now we met in Bahrain I asked
him what was going on was life you've
gotten married recently to a Bahraini I
said where did that happen how did you
at Disneyland so statisticians in the
audience to bar Rainey's never met each
other
roughly a popular domestic population a
home citizen population about 600,000
and they met at Disneyland and I had
never met him here but we met in Bahrain
don't underestimate the value of luck
kismet serendipity in all of this those
things are on your side too
those things are on your side but
meeting this young man and he was in
local dress and I wouldn't have
recognized them if I knew him very well
frankly in in local dress led me to talk
a little bit about a movie I saw on the
way home this is now Friday we still
have stuff that happened this morning
that I'm going to talk about so nowhere
he's on that and what was that movie
hidden figures and for this young man in
local dress he certainly would have been
a hidden figure for me but my flight was
coming back through Dubai and what's
what's the issue these days and it may
be extended as many of you know that
there are seven countries around the
world in which you cannot carry a
computer on if you're traveling to
England or the United States a computer
or a laptop and I had a computer and a
laptop so my flight change so there's a
long line and they take you things and
put them in a basket and so on and so
forth and it was a long line on Emirates
a terrific airline and a gentleman
behind me was very upset because it was
clearly going to take five or ten or
fifteen minutes longer to get on the
plane than he had hoped
and finally after being less than
friendly with a couple of people trying
to get a small moved along very quickly
he said to someone who's clearly South
Asian in front of him who was working
whose rules are these anyway implying of
course that the domestic in this case in
Dubai they had set up rules and I looked
at him I looked back at him and said
there are rules and I'm not sure if you
understood what I meant by our rules so
I had to clarify I said they're American
rules very embarrassed hidden figures
because the four or five or six people
that were working that day filling boxes
were all South Asian as is roughly half
the popular
nation of Bahrain hidden figures whose
rules are these anyway Wow it tolerance
another lesson along the way pretty
important it's a complicated world
hidden figures are everywhere on that
movie and it's a movie full filled with
inspiration John Glenn going to the moon
so on and so forth and obviously issues
of race and whatnot there is a terrific
line I've been thinking about that line
quite a bit it's when a woman in the in
the movie says to one of our
african-american counterparts the
following you know despite what you all
think I have nothing against you all
this is 1961 and the response is I know
pause I know that's what you probably
believed I think about that in any walk
of life when we say I'm doing my best
well I know versus I know that's what
you probably believe I'm not a racist
I know I'm trying any one of those
things a whole lot of difference
tolerance and then I've been thinking a
little bit about some things that I say
to my first second third and fourth year
students in the principles of economics
at the end of the semester in kind of a
last lecture setting and I'm going to
steal a couple of things from those and
I'm a little bit worried about doing
that because a couple of students have
come back and sat in on that last
lecture a second time and one of them
came up to me and said hey you know some
of the things you said were the same as
they were last year and I said yes
that's because the things that
influenced me and shape the way I live
my life don't change semester to
semester most of them don't a Tale of
Two Cities
it was the best of times the worst of
times
think about Aleppo and think about
Munich why Munich who's those incredible
pictures of people showing up and being
welcomed on trains and elsewhere that's
the world you're walking into and when
people say we live in interesting times
I don't actually believe that because
everyone can say that of every
generation we're always living
interesting times in sports we have this
important quality in athletes and that's
a tolerance for pain how tolerant are
you in pain can you play through an
injury and that's a great attribute for
an athlete when you're running a
marathon can you get through that twenty
one twenty first mile and so on it seems
to me a much more important attribute is
intolerance but intolerance in the pain
of others intolerance in the pain of
others that sounds like a really very
important characteristic for all of you
all of us to live our lives by
intolerance in the pain of others and
then finally let me tell you I don't
like May I don't like Mondays during the
summer or Tuesdays Wednesdays Thursdays
or Friday
I love September I love Mondays during
the school year
not so much Fridays because it is never
the case never the case that I walk into
a classroom and I'm not happy about
being there or enjoying what I'm doing
that's a pretty good way to live life
no don't live on Park Avenue that's okay
but walking in and doing what you do and
enjoying it and being passionate about
it every day
and in my other life in a soccer world
yes there's some tough days there
particularly the last year or two but on
the news a little bit too much and we
lose some games every now and then but
in my teaching life there's not a day
that I don't love it but I'm not
passionate about it so does Pat being
passionate about something guarantee you
that you're going to be happy no and the
stats majors on those of you and the two
biggest groups the stats and the
quantitative methods and social sciences
will tell you it that's actually bigger
than the set where the stats folks
anyway and the quantitative folks were
you smaller but louder one more time
with the stats folks
okay it won't guarantee you happiness
but it will surely increase the
probability so in closing
I wish you all the very very best in the
hope that you will passionately practice
compassionate intolerance in everything
you do good luck the world's waiting for
you enjoy thank you Thank You professor
karate I think we now arrive at the
central point of the ceremony the
presentation of the Masters candidates
we ask you to come forth as we call your
name in recognition of your individual
accomplishments petit matias student
affairs officer of Columbia University's
Chinese students and scholars
Association will read the names of the
Masters candidates as they approach the
podium
receiving a Masters of Arts in
african-american studies
Alejandro McGee VAR d a--'s tutorial
receiving a Masters of Arts in American
Studies Tiffany back
emmeline Fitz and Kim McNee Minh Sarah
Pearlman Shapiro Hanna navoo ADIZ Otto
Kahn Priyanka Prashad Meredith Kieffer
receiving a Masters of Arts in
anthropology Michelle wouldn't leave
each year Marwa is Sean Colin
petit Melanie the shamp Terrence
Sean tongue and Bend and burg shiza a
med
Malvina kevala Daniel West the shock of
start mm-hmm pisaq are us receiving a
Masters of Arts in art history and
archaeology Laura pollution maneuver
yaagh a key Sara Eisen alia Fenner
receiving a Masters of Arts and
biological sciences alexander alloy
[Applause]
receiving a Masters of Arts and
biomedical informatics Lily Anjou ich
lengua
Shruti khadiyah Darwin Chen Shing Ely
receiving a Masters of Arts in
biotechnology
Amanda show Catherine Helen 'mobile
Andrea breader Patricia both Sokka
Mellish are - nah Rami cut kuta moti sri
three
[Applause]
mess met John Epoque new Tazawa soo
Santa Rita
Denarius Frasier
[Applause]
Katie Delgado John Crocker Shing equal
pay Siwon leave Wharton yeah yeah leave
some Chi hoon
Deanna Carillo Ponce's to park
Christopher who receiving a Masters of
Arts in art history and archaeology
Roxanne Smith receiving a Masters of
Arts in biomed biological sciences
Daisuke is Aki Stella
Kim Elsa Oh Jung
my Ferrari ramen John Brito Sarah
I'll asam Anastasia or nuts receiving a
Masters of Arts in chemistry Hong Yeo
receiving a Masters of Arts in classical
studies Debra zhukovsky Eleni
Giza Nicolas Mazar Amelia Eichengreen
receiving a Masters of Arts in classics
Lance
Tomas receiving a Masters of Arts and
climate Society
Carolyn bulk so weak chatterjee eating
tongue
Davern Chung dahveed colbus okay Holly
Davidson Alexandra harden Eriksson
Carissa Lim Jing angleene sorry Benjamin
macaroni receiving a Masters of Arts and
earth and environmental sciences Brianna
Malad receiving a Masters of Arts and
climate and society
Joanne Norris Lydia share Alice
Stevenson Sarah
so John Vivaro mo Claudia Villar Lehman
Allison v VJ gasps romance
yeah Yu Shu Qi Feng yang you wrong you
yet young Jojo receiving a Masters of
Arts and earth and environmental science
Laura Gruenberg receiving a Masters of
Arts in East Asian languages and
cultures
Kahoot Yu Tong Xiao Xiao Lu Shu ether
who Henning you want dong Jin liao Chen
che ye leo Monica Cho though he comes
June 1 by Mihoko wheeler
Leroy Spencer receiving a Masters of
Arts in East Asia regional studies
geeijo monkey Zhu Xin Ren Leo Nicholas
leo jazz songs tongue aiming Andrew
Patrick Melvin James Matthew Novak
receiving a Masters of Arts in ecology
evolution and Environmental Biology
destiny star deli
Andrew Michael but saw grace Luthor
brandy cannon Nene
Ubbe Wendy Flores Margaret O'Brien
Elinor p.m. on Yuki Baba
Tricia Gunter Alexander tae Kuk
receiving a Masters of Arts in economics
when halfway
norine receive a means to the jaw Fung
Lee young Joshua nian you wore the Chi
hung lateen Li Ling long shall Jeong
Jeong
how can each end receiving a Masters of
Arts in statistics Hmong Johnny each
Eastland USO receiving a Masters of Arts
and economic youth home food
you mean Leo myuca Kihara DPN Ling Qi
Jong evening Ho Chi Chi one
Travis do Walter Ryan the mori phone
Esther young Johnny Sancho
Lu Cheng Han Wei Zhang hung great Cole
static Chemical Co you pink guy
gen Lee Joshua chance Linda whoo Henry
ciao
Beatrice siharan Ratched Almeida Brendan
Hume Jake Murrow be the Juicy J us t
lock the dark go Colin Nidhi Marty
JT Ramez Sabbath you mangu
he also kim joon saw means is worried to
Braja young belong
yeah jin kim han you great hand
receiving a Masters of Arts in English
literature rusty Ashok on Maxine are
inant Olivia ball Amalia Francisco
receiving a Masters of Arts in film
studies Nicholas Bollinger Briand gentry
and more receiving a Masters of Arts in
global thought Nikki Ehrlich Giulio Wong
Nicholas Jones and a broadband Martha
King Alicia Wong
Leslie Goldman Franco Jeremy um
hi be Chauncey on Zenith vara are long
gone
Sean mixed McClung deluxe Mancini Oh
Georgie
Christopher Lynn Omar al Matawa Dara
Larson emanuelly Wiley being wrong
Alex Caro sodium Kim nyla al thani
Nicole the Jovic Elena
ho-young be receiving a Masters of Arts
in history
Robin rice receiving a Masters of Arts
and history and leaders literature even
garden search : son I see you I see
Cadiz Lauren Clark groups are me Sara
Lee Joo the porn Elizabeth Scott air
horn sinube balloon marina Koontz Cova
receiving a Masters of Arts in Human
Rights studies Alan Williams America
sorry Christine Bilsky
Nakia appear in only a junior
great
f
melody mills
aerial Garfinkel Roya Picasa
Heather Gilbreth
Rose cut each sheet of pet car
Elizabeth Pattinson Ryan P man I've her
car waha
you junk in Mariana Gonzalez Molly
Stevens Michelle monsoon soda China
Hayley well Maria rouhani Kimberly Cohen
Hanna
Yara Sahar Matthew reuleaux Giselle
Kasim Sierra mcwrap Fatima a slump
receiving a Masters of Arts in Islamic
studies Hina Sahar Mooney Rudy receiving
a Masters of Arts in Italian Christina
McGrath Genny Clarke strife receiving a
Masters of Arts in Latin American and
Caribbean regional studies Luis Lopez
Florencia Orleans Oni Renee Suzette
Lauren yovanna Miceli Enrique Lopez
Christie strong men receiving a Masters
of Arts in mathematics with a
specialization in the mathematics of
finance Kevin stone Chung hoon Lee Hamza
bench Chi Minh Xiao Dre nan Jiang da Wei
Hong Jin Chen Sun Hey
dongjun wei-yin Minji one you XI Li long
young for you ha Xiang Liang
Ling way home blue Chandi me an un lo
ding Joe wait Yali see our dung
Gillian - Christopher Li Jing Fung Jang
-
one liao see Joe taught Wharton she knew
a pan mung beans
floristone wait when Jung oh I think the
person receiving a Masters of Arts in
Middle Eastern South Asian and African
Studies McCauley finger Milnes Yara
sumac receiving a Masters of Arts in
history
Alvaro Miranda receiving a Masters of
Arts in modern European studies been
tense receiving a Masters of Arts and
Museum anthropology Catherine blanks
Caroline blank Alice knew John Teixeira
Kaitlin seller
Kimberly know Marissa are risky Noel um
Sarah a bush Leah Catherine Sabella
Veronica Jacob Edmondson Shannon Stewart
Alexandra Carper Cristina Chavez
franceska Saldana who chemo abdul-fattah
receiving a Masters of Arts in oral
history Bonnie Garcia a limb jelly
cooling Steven Palmer you tone one Deena
ash ha ha ha
Shao Yin leak Emma Portland Robin
Minister Monica Lou Retton de Espinosa
receiving a Masters of Arts in
philosophy co-found a shion's of physics
kathleen tatum receiving a Master of
Arts in modern art critical and cue
torial study Mary or Nancy ha Georgia
horn Taylor fish Emile Alexandra
receiving a Masters of Arts in
philosophy
ae-jong Natalia roguish Peter joo-heon
Marco gretchy Elizabeth Ben
Luke Shamu Philip your
[Music]
Antonio Garcia chibita Laurent Haleh
Nathan Jones
Inessa presses key Joel Fong's one page
from Kowski Katherine cone receiving a
Masters of Arts in political science
bend our afiad Natasha Rodriguez Tina
Kraus Olsen
Jeffrey Lim Jeong ha left early Gabriel
Neil Alexander Thomas son Adam Robert
Adam go sign Claire Abraham Keegan Tatum
Guillaume Allison
Zachary Lim was themed some row mark
Rothrock Joanne walk 10 told you Michael
house
receiving a Masters of Arts and
quantitative methods in the social
sciences Meredith meek Michels grishko
Sarah Vasquez Azadi Rebecca Portman
Nigel De Jong for Peter Darsh
dendera follow Putin you team Cheung us
long etho Joe Danny Chen are you AG king
nama way laughs Wong when foo Arnold
loud Stefan bronzer Jill UN ten Jessica
Kim Daniel pro nobis even McAlpine
Jennifer can Jonah
Erica killbride ling by you heal and how
Leo Miriam makini good yen Chen Angela
Rio
Pedro Jose spirit apni Salam Davi
Gustavo Suarez
Tessa Eduardo monkian Olea Michael
Sargon Alexandra Roth IRAs Brandon whoa
receiving a Masters of Arts and
religions Chelsey Naylor receiving a
Masters of Arts in Russia Georgia and
East Europe regional studies Jocelyn
Meekins receiving a Masters of Arts in
Russian translation Elaine Wilson
receiving a Masters of Arts in sociology
Marva hurmati definite ah
camels whinny Xuan juice
Luke's vasty Yi Xuan job y'all sure any
one Gina lamb
Andrew Byrom Jamie song un soup erin
elizabeth cube Jane Wong Rima ill or
folly receiving a Masters of Arts in
South Asian Studies Salva hawk a DP -
snoop Labib ah Ali risk even a Masters
of Arts and statistics Cheung Engel
Hong Hong Jong un yo young you a war
child chan phan ling Jie Xiao Han Jung
Yong Shi tell Jin Jing Fung Chan Sung
Jung Lee Jung Yeo Joo low-cost show yeah
II Leo Shan Chun Qiu one Dalian Jing er
Lindo
so Andrew malaria
[Applause]
Eric John Thackery Chan Li Na Li equal
do mean hot on job wait on ya tink soon
mean how died the I eat on the way Hmong
great son you're on Shu can mean Karen
you us one face ow
he's and one Schwinn son carton
surely some you hands-on mungyu and how
can sow here Cecilia loop yo Joe tell
you so ciao ciao one you far the race
son Dina one Winston one shall you Joe
sure you won the palme when when
Jingzhou done so done more one us lee
hong fan li the UN yo here young son the
shrinking you Ching Wong
how chanson do you ensure total jingling
channel each wingman King mo Lincoln
song Mugato Lin one utensil yen one
tongue will sing youto Jin's younger one
you tone you loo 1 1 e Jung Jin Chun
yunjeong kingdom so seen how who
Brida dessert
Stephanie topic yeah you intend thing
ying-ying en un tongue her when Jang
tae-hee tom zachary new nigga I can new
get cursing who Shui in channel tool in
one chun-li shelf Angie's to me Jung hee
so judgment Oh Oh son
how you won
when hung Wow
wait shirt yow the tall one
hee haw cow
sir you one eat someone mean one
so the dice
we push where key when you can we see
loop when fun
one Sanchez Diego Sanchez austerity this
is Juan Pablo campus Gutierrez he can
shoot Fatiha
one phone call you Tom Ian King way Lee
Jung Jung Hwan LUN Liao ow
Leo Lin Yao - how long
PUF on a wastin
hammy our Nashville TN surely go on you
II need Sun give in to you and ran one
hand me thank you
hiding out or actually
[Applause]
and now my parting remarks to the
graduating class during your stay in
this institution we have endeavored to
train you how to think write and speak
like a member of an academic field as a
participant in an intellectual community
defined by the mores and conventions of
your discipline leaving in the process
little time or room for much else indeed
looking back at the foundational myth of
the modern University one can detect
readily a desire to place the
institution in a location of exception
with respect to the social as an
enterprise that derives its force and
reason for being from its insularity
from its distance from societal concerns
this is part and parcel of the
apprenticeship model of graduate
education and explains to a large degree
the sense of loneliness that we have all
felt at one time or another while in
graduate school as if we all had to
recreate for ourselves and within
ourselves the principle tenants of our
chosen discipline and thus engage in a
project of intellectual self fashioning
that necessarily had to keep the world
at bay given the effort that you have
extend expended in achieving this goal
you would be justified in thinking that
the triumph that you celebrate today
surely should be enough and yet the
Spanish philosopher Jose Ortega y Gasset
wrote in the earlier 20th century an
aphorism that comes to mind to describe
what I'm hoping to convey to you as you
leave this institution
yo soy Jo amici constantia et Nola's
ahluwalia no metal whoa yo which can be
loosely translated as
I am myself and my circumstance and if I
do not redeem it
I cannot redeem myself since November of
last year most academic institutions in
the nation have been buffeted by the
unexpected outcome of a general election
whose principal ideological ideological
contours appear to issue from a version
of this country that is felt by some of
us to be unsettling and unfamiliar I do
not want to challenge or bemoan the
results of that election here but to
invoke it as an object lesson for all of
us using the very analytical tools that
you have learned at Columbia and which
we live by
we should endeavor to understand the
phenomenon down to its root causes but
perhaps more important is for us to be
chastened by the very surprise with
which we received this event for in
hindsight now all of the pieces were
readily available to us that would have
allowed us almost to predict as opposed
to being surprised by the results of the
last election the indifference at the
radical concentration of wealth and
resulting income inequalities that is
regard for a lower standard of living
for many of our middle class citizens
the shrugging of shoulders are the
seemingly wanton police killings of
black citizens the lack of concern with
the pollution of the public sphere with
misinformation the conundrum that on the
one hand our current economic system has
ushered in the wondrous wondrous world
in which we live but that it also has a
continual propensity to naturalize
inequalities and to produce narratives
of success about individual effort that
justify those inequalities all of these
circumstances point to the loss of our
sense of the Commons of the belief that
we have some responsibility to our
brethren and that our fundamental
some should be that what is best is what
is good for the largest number of people
have we allowed ourselves to see these
phenomena we would not have been
staggered by the events of November the
university may have been created to keep
the world at bay outside its walls but
we should not allow the mythological
foundation to determine our relationship
with our surroundings the very distilled
concentration the monomaniacal attention
to your intellectual projects that has
allowed you to be where you are today is
a decided strength but it can also lead
imperceptibly to a withdrawal from the
world that is not that different and it
effects from outright neglect struggling
against the insular experience in which
you had to invert your self to be
perfect successful in graduate school
will perhaps be the most taxing the most
demanding task you will undertake in the
next chapter of your life everything
that you have learned the Columbia will
only acquire its full significance when
you are able to articulate its meaning
for the Commons hence in spite of the
requisite headlong plunge into our
disciplinary Miglia we must never lose
sight of the larger social context that
will endow our work with its ultimate
significance we are as a society at
peril of losing that sense of
responsibility toward the common good
without which our work will be
diminished but more important without
which no understanding or application of
justice may sustain itself your studies
have endowed you with powerful
analytical tools and equally effective
powers of persuasion and you should use
them to protect the health of the social
compact to strengthen the resilience of
our common bonds
strive to be happy as an individual but
always keep in mind
Ortega's s admonition that if you do not
also endeavour to redeem your
circumstance your own fulfillment will
be in jeopardy never lose sight with the
fact that many persons even absolute
strangers have contributed to this
personal success of yours that we
celebrate today and that the best way to
acknowledge that death is through your
rena renewed commitment to the essential
business of being human among and
alongside other human beings we arrived
then at the end of this magnificent
ceremony go forth to be our
representatives and emissaries to the
world and all of us at Columbia will
rejoice in your inevitable achievements
make us and your relatives and friends
prouder still about you than we are
today
will the candidates please stand so that
we may give them a final round of
applause
[Music]
you are all invited candidate friends
and family to a champagne reception
immediately following the ceremony at
every Plaza
Avery Plaza under the tent I ask all of
you though to wait until after the
faculty and the candidates have ascended
the row library steps before exiting
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]